[Música]
buenas tardes aquí tenéis mirad yo os
prometo ser breve pero me gustaría
contaros una historia no hace mucho
recientemente estaba yo la tarde
cualquiera tranquilo en casa cuando en
estas que me empieza a sonar el teléfono
en el bolsillo entonces evidentemente lo
saco para ver quién es y miro con horror
que es un amigo mío y digo con horror
porque es un amigo mío especialmente
pesado un amigo brasas todos tenemos uno
no sabéis de lo que me estoy hablando
entonces claro yo empezaba a pensar la
verdad es que no me apetecía nada
cogerle el teléfono este señor ahora yo
sé que me va a tener 25 minutos media
hora de conversación vengo de un día
malo en la universidad agotado cansado
un poco entonces ya empezaba a
figurar me excusas y tuve ahí mi buen
rato de conversación que este es un tío
sensacional
nos queremos mucho el músico amigos
muchos años y nos apreciamos mucho
mutuamente pero yo sabía lo que venía
entre esos confesaré ahora que estamos
en intimidad que estuve dudando un
segundo
decía se lo cojo no se lo cojo se lo
cojo no se lo cojo
se la acaba cogiendo y claro yo os
preguntaréis uno qué tiene que ver esto
con el riesgo de no arriesgar ingenuos
de vosotros que os pensabais que el 3
por otra cosa no no no no no no el
riesgo es exactamente esto tendríamos
pues cogerle el teléfono a vuestro amigo
el pesado vaya si es o no el riesgo
dejando que me explique me da la
sensación de que cuando hablamos de
riesgo tendemos a sobrevalorar lo así
entre nosotros y creo que puede ser
porque lo entendamos mal tenemos una
concepción del riesgo que es incorrecta
cuando nos hablan de riesgo en seguida
tendemos a asimilarlo a dos grandes
riesgos no por dos vías o bien académico
o bien profesional arriesga el tío que
teniendo un trabajo estable decide irse
australia a la aventura a ver qué pasa
qué osado qué valiente qué atrevido o
arriesga el chaval que pudiendo elegir
estudiar cualquier carrera pues decide
estudiar
pongamos filología de las lenguas
muertas porque descubre que su pasión
qué loco cómo se lo está jugando qué tío
más arriesgado
siento deciros que ninguno de los dos ha
arriesgado nada porque convendremos en
que para arriesgar tiene que haber algo
que perder o no si no sólo somos
malabaristas si sobre la cuerda floja es
cierto pero con una red de seguridad
debajo lo peor que nos puede pasar es
caernos y tener que volver a escalar y
ponerse en danza otra vez porque vamos a
hacer un ejercicio de imaginación que es
lo peor que podría pasarle a nuestros
dos colegas anteriores
pues el que se ha ido australia que le
salga mal la jugada y tenga que volver y
empezar a trabajar de nuevo en un puesto
similar al que dejo
y nuestro colega el estudiante de
sumerio y arameo pues está a tiempo de
cambiar de carrera ocho veces no de
hecho es una práctica relativamente
habitual entre los estudiantes cambiar
de trayectoria por lo tanto la primera
conclusión es que lo que llamamos riesgo
no lo está estrictamente en el campo
académico o profesional el riesgo no
deja de ser un riesgo relativo
y entiendo que es cierto que conviene no
frivolizar con este tema pero lo cierto
es que en españa tenemos gracias a dios'
cierta estabilidad garantizada el índice
de desarrollo humano nos sitúa en el
puesto 26º del mundo entero pero más aún
no llegan tiempos de 'vacas flacas' como
las recientes crisis económicas mucho se
ha estudiado y escrito sobre como por
cuestiones culturales los tejidos
sociales y familiares en nuestro país
ayudan a paliar los efectos nocivos de
estas crisis hay que pensar en los
abuelos que se hacen cargo del cuidado
de sus nietos en los padres que re
admiten en casa a los hijos que hace
tiempo que marcharon
en definitiva en españa vamos sobre
seguro en cierta medida con dolorosas
excepciones desde luego pero es cierto
que no arriesgamos de verdad
con un poco de suerte ninguno de los que
estamos aquí hoy presentes ha arriesgado
de verdad jamás en su vida es probable
que no tengamos que hacerlo nunca
ninguno jamás
viento hay una excepción
arriesgamos de verdad en las relaciones
personales
en estas así que somos malabaristas
sobre la cuerda floja y sin red debajo
en caída libre
porque estas relaciones no tienen
protección jurídica no tienen ningún
medio de asegurar tampoco la protección
de un bien o un interés propio o
particular
en definitiva quien arriesga arriesga
quien se compromete con algo quien se
compromete hasta el punto de poder ser
dañado quien se compromete con algo que
puede llegar a hundirle
arriesgan quienes se juran fidelidad en
la salud y en la enfermedad en la
fortuna y en la desgracia hasta que la
muerte les separe arriesgan quienes
deciden traer una vida al mundo más aún
arriesgan esos padres que conocen el
defecto de su feto y deciden seguir
adelante con él
arriesgan de verdad quienes se entregan
en una amistad leal sincera
incondicional
incluso se me ocurre arriesga a quien
renuncia a sus propias preferencias por
consagrar su vida al servicio de los
demás y digo esto pensando en un buen
amigo mío que el próximo septiembre
entra en el seminario
todos estos tienen una cosa en común y
es que al final podemos concluir que
arriesga el que ama
sin necesidad de cañerías sin
cursilerías pero efectivamente parece
que el que arriesga es el que ama el que
se entrega
aun a riesgo de ser dañado
y ahora que ya hemos localizado el
riesgo de verdad el auténtico claro cabe
preguntarse por qué deberíamos
arriesgarnos
pues porque en estas relaciones
personales si existe el riesgo de no
arriesgar
porque el amor nos hace cultivar toda
una serie de virtudes que nos hacen
mejores que nos hacen más perfectos
porque el amor es paciente es afable no
es egoísta no lleva las cuentas no se
irrita no es maleducado nos hace
entrenar la generosidad la comprensión
el perdón la empatía
y quien decide no arriesgar no volcarse
en estas relaciones personales corre el
riesgo de perderse todo esto
no me gustaría que estas ideas cayese en
un pozo sin fondo ésta puede ser una
charla más de esas de las que salimos
todos super concienciados pero que a
tres días vista no han producido ningún
efecto por eso me voy a sumar a la
petición de poner los deberes yo sé que
no habíais unido esto los voy a poner
tareas voluntarias yo prometo no pasar
lista pero estaría bien que los aquí
presentes o los que estéis siguiendo
esto por retransmisión dediquéis un
minuto a pensar en alguien a quien
deberíais dar un toque quizás ese amigo
del que hace tiempo que no sabéis nada
visitar a vuestros padres que están
deseando veros después de tanto tiempo
perdonar quizás a ese hermano que es la
vuelto a jugar una vez más
un propósito
pequeño si hace falta que sea factible
pero un propósito
porque en definitiva el riesgo es esto
el riesgo está en amar
el riesgo es cogerle el teléfono a
vuestro amigo el brasas
y recuerda aquí si hay riesgo no
arriesgar
os prometí ser breve y lo prometido es
deuda muchas gracias
[Aplausos]